[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce matin en présence de la ministre
madame venir une hache et a été
inaugurée la filière infrastructures
numériques avec les acteurs de la
filière infrastructures numériques que
sont les opérateurs les équipementiers
les syndicats et toutes les entreprises
qui sont liées à l'infrastructure
numérique et bien sûr le pôle systematic
qui rassemble beaucoup d'acteurs de
cette filière
et donc c était au sein du pôle
systematic on est très très heureux
d'accueillir la ministre et les
représentants des différentes
structuration de cette filière la
filière infrastructures numériques en
fait ça parle de la 5g de la
structuration des équipements numériques
qui demain vont être très importants
pour générer des données et donc changer
la ville change et d'un mobilité changer
l'énergie la cinquième génération c'est
celle qui vient après la 4g mais en fait
c'est plus que une génération d'après la
cinquième génération ça sera beaucoup
plus de débit sur les téléphones
portables beaucoup plus de débit lié
tout avec tout un tas de capteurs qu'on
appelle des objets l'internet des objets
donc ça va être beaucoup de données
distribués est liée à ces données ça va
être le développement est la mise en
place de l'intelligence artificielle à
différents niveaux et dans ce cas ce
qu'on appelle des services cognitif
beaucoup plus intelligent et c'est pour
ça qu'on parle de smart cities de ville
intelligente de de mobilité différente
avec la voiture autonome parce qu'on va
en même temps une infrastructure
numérique
archi connectés hyperconnecté produits
productrice de beaucoup de données et
très interactif pour mettre en place des
nouveaux services au 21ème siècle
l'impact de la numérisation est immense
et il faut pour cela se doter d'une
infrastructure numérique forte
c'est aussi un enjeu de souveraineté
c'est pourquoi l'état est fortement
impliqué dans le développement de cette
filière
[Musique]